what is happening reject nation I'm
gorilla and I'm John Humphrey so someone
is backing them up no right now the
whole time no to it all day you could
have heard a pin drop out this window a
patreon one of our exclusive perks is
you pledge a certain amount any video
you request we will do doesn't matter if
it popular or not or if it's a subject
you'd like us to talk on whatever it is
if it's pornography a snuff video we
don't care don't care we'll watch
anything how to survive that
snowpocalypse is today's video and
submitted by Andrew Hayes Oh Andrew
Hayes this video trending on YouTube 187
views published last year in February
it's got nine life it's got nine likes
let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
hi guys welcome to another episode of
position chat I'm your host princess
louise day just I'm your host Louie Mac
oh well today we all know you're
supposed to have our guest Shawn team
well do sir
circumstances he is unable to make it
today so have someone almost as Korea's
John Cena we have our award-winning
director Jamie Shaw must be friends of
Andrew welcome to the show thanks for
having me no problem at all carbs so we
have heard that you did you're a
snowpocalypse one here how is that
that's pretty great actually
okay so here we have a few questions
pre-prepared by the viewers of the show
let's get started alright so what kind
of impact do you think that your film
has among the audience well I want them
to know the dangers of snow if every
year during the snow there's people get
killed and sometimes sadly hurt but sure
real good result is something to know
that the snow load kill you and you will
die as you can see we have some phone
calls coming through so hi Becky here on
the show
okay so first of all this snowpocalypse
movie total [ __ ]
I turn making a hot sauce on scram like
in the movie and they're still snow my
backyard you do know that was all fake
right it was really almost 5000 people
have been killed by the snow from and
your stupid movie didn't help at all
what do you have to save yourself well
luckily we made a survival guide and
time of the symbolist so hopefully that
will help well let's take a view shall
we
while all their money the Turkmen that
at your age and the nez I'm gonna show
you how fun
so I'll tell ya the buddy slow oh you're
in a coffee pie
[Music]
dear acting skill and your mother's
judge your step
identifying the priest you got to go
outside and see then any snow on the
ground
oh sure he's ripping it like myself we
hi my name is Brad and I'm better
survivor snowpocalypse one step too late
keeping warm Kitchell time weakness oh
man make it do it you're naked
very full naked man step through it
because it's a bond
there's no pocalypse you're gonna need
food luckily all we need to eat is some
snow
you're 40 right what will you do so the
blue snow hahahahaha right step forth
the god get rid of the snow somehow so
the first thing we do to get rid of Joe
is start shoveling like passes over step
5
if you can't shovel snow you bring the
bucket of milk and white fire oh my oh
my carefully
that's baby better Rio that looks like
real fire thrill and a real fuel
we'll both of the professional
government I guess wasn't in my contract
I didn't I didn't agree to this this
[ __ ] it's what we'll like to spring yeah
I'm ready
well that was good job Andrew I love
done Andrew I'm good 60 or like this
time people have been killed but it's no
populous with any our has drastically
changed jr. cement guy bring it to its
ruin is Becky thousands they are best
Mikey Felton 10,000 people only killed
by the storm
after watching her video she kind of
cancel the show now I just forgot you're
on the show this is it writing he
co-wrote it
Oh remember remembered all the sketches
we would make one there's like no real
crew yeah
get your ugly mates to go on the iMovie
editing system plopping down the camera
you know throwing off a few takes yeah
Heather fun because it's just it just
does to putting together something fun
cutting our teeth and made out yeah I
got first sketch we made before we even
had like 20,000 followers
oh man way back in st. Patrick's Day
yeah oh boy getting pinched on st.
Patrick revenge for minutes how we try
to get like Mike's yes now it's work out
labor
yeah no it's like we gotta figure this
now this is going to be probably
actually very stressed yeah but in my
days to three days shooting a week of
editing yeah no and inevitably one of
these days is going to be tense for some
reason I don't like one of us is gonna
flip out of something and then yeah and
that these this is the good old days
Andrew Hayes my friend patches
o'houlihan all character right never
mind me that you seem very comfortable
on camera and I know why you agreed to
be a part of the sketch you're trying to
sleep with that Becky trick oh right
right uh hey Becky if you're watching
this video you did a really good job I
want you to know Andrew he is a
sensitive guy with a great heart he is
passionate he is enthusiastic I mean you
know all these things you hung out with
him in person because probably they just
seem shy to tell you though that he
really is into you and he would love to
tap that ass go ahead
Jason Kathina hi drew uh Andrew Hayes
has an award on his wall I've seen into
his bedroom a few times leather camera
not our various Google Hangouts and he
seems like a highly decorated lad a jack
of many trades uh and I mean you know
this is like watching a Tom Hardy
performance or is like you know half his
face was a scare belly eye patches and
hats and stuff but like that one
beautiful blue eye it does have
beautiful eyes does that do this a
beautiful eye and a beautiful enthusiam
and a beautiful smile
I give praise to Andrew Hayes did it
Andrew Hayes face Becky that's her name
right Jamie sharp you have been taking
me you've been talking to a mystery girl
oh well Jamie I took the chemistry you
had in the video with Louie al bigots
there I think you got to go settle with
Andrew Hayes and that'll is the key word
here you're going to need to settle with
Andrew it's the only way to do he needs
to lose his virginity you're going to
have to learn how to settle for the best
well thank that they're vegetarians
Sarah those are your sketch here Oh
Jamie Jamie directed edited and wrote it
- yeah press it's wicked alright they
keep it out like like watching this just
warmed up my soul because it did make me
think back to the time where this is
like yeah you know we've got a camera
yet we're putting credits on things
we're getting our little troupe going
and that warms my heart so yeah keep it
up well Jamie now that I know you're a
director and writer can all that don't
go out with Andrew Hayes come out to
California and let's hang out together
yes
because Kim huh